This fabulous spiky
scarf is a Knit-1 design.
Impressive as it is, it
really isn't hard to knit.
The key is understanding that we're using
partial knitting or short rows to create
full pyramid shapes and
half pyramid shapes.
Now don't be overwhelmed.
There are only two knitting sequences.
The half pyramids allow us to alternate
the position of the full pyramids for the
design.
Let's get started.
We'll cast on 48 stitches with any
method and knit for a couple rows.
The pattern tells us to start
with the carriage on the left.
Now throughout the knitting, you'll
keep your carriage set to hold.
We'll get started by knitting our first
pyramid over the left 24 needles, so we'll
put the right 24 needles
into hold position.
Throughout this whole pattern, we'll
be placing needles in and out of hold
position - opposite the carriage
In order to keep the stitches from popping
off as you're knitting, the biggest
challenge is to keep
weight on the knitting.
Either use weights, your fingers
or a combination of both.
Start working the partial knitting by
pulling into hold the first needle that's
opposite the carriage.
Keep putting one needle into hold
with every pass of the carriage.
You need to ensure on every row
that the stitches knit correctly.
Now notice I'm not wrapping any needles.
This creates the eyelets that
are a feature of this design.
Opposite the carriage keep putting needles
into hold until you have a single needle
in working position.
And then begin returning needles back into
working position.Opposite the carriage
return one needle to work with
every pass of the carriage.
Do this until all 24
needles are back in work.
Be sure to keep weight on those
stitches so they all knit correctly.
They'll tend to pop up.
Continue to put needles back into work,
one at a time, opposite the carriage until
all of those 24 needles are
back into working position.
Now notice on the last pass of the
carriage, I'm going to put two needles
back into working position.
It's just the way it works out.
I've ended with my carriage on the
left and my first pyramid is complete.
I still have 24 needles in a
hold position on the right,
and I put some weight on
the stitches on the right.
It's time to start knitting.
The second pyramid.
Now keeping that carriage set to hold.
I'll put the needles in the right into
middle position, so they'll knit on the
next pass of the carriage, but I'm going
to immediately start the partial knitting
by keeping the first needle
in the right in hold.
Knit across to the right.
I didn't mean to complicate this.
If you forgot to keep this one needle out
at this point, you can just un-knit it, or
you could start your partial
knitting on the next row.
Hang in there with me.
We're going to be working on the right 24
needles, so I'm all done with the needles
on the left.
That first pyramid is finished, so we'll
put those needles into hold position.
We're all done with them.
Working over the right 24 needles, just
like before, opposite the carriage.
I'll put one needle into hold.
Paying attention to keep those stitches
knitting correctly, add weight, or use
your fingers.
Work your partial knitting.
One needle to hold opposite
the carriage knit across.
One needle to in hold opposite
Until there's only one needle
left in working position.
Then you'll begin to return needles into
work, one at a time opposite the carriage.
Needle in work.
Knit across.
Needle in work knitting across.
You should have 24 needles in work,
and the second pyramid is complete.
That's the first section of our repeats.
For the next section, we're going to knit
a partial pyramid on each side with a full
pyramid in the middle.
We'll start by partial knitting
over 12 stitches this time.
The short rows are the same,
but we're only working.
The increases in decreases on one side.
Carriage is on the right.
The carriage is still in hold.
Put all the needles into hold position
except the 12 needles right next to the
carriage.
As before, we'll put one needle opposite
the carriage into hold knit across, knit
back, put the next needle into hold.
Knit across, knit back.
Continue until there's only
one needle in working position.
Then start the short row increases by
putting one needle back into work again.
Always opposite the carriage.
Knit across and back.
One needle into work.
Repeat until all 12 needles
are back into working position.
Can you see our first half pyramid?
This is the start of the
second section of the scarf.
Next is the center section,
and it will be a full pyramid.
Now to keep things straight, I like
to use a pencil to mark my needle bed.
For this project.
I'm going to mark the center 24 needles.
To start the second pyramid,
put those center 24 needles into
middle positions, so they'll knit.
Leave the left 12 needles in hold.
We're going to do that next.
Just leave those stitches in hold knit
across the needles and work, which is a
total of 36 needles.
Now your carriage is on the left.
We're done with those 12 half pyramid
needles that are on the right.
We're all done with that little section.
So put those 12 half pyramid
needles into hold position.
Only the center 24 needles
are in working position.
And we'll start the partial knitting and
creating a full pyramid . Opposite the
carriage.
Put one needle into a hold,
knit across.
Opposite the carriage.
Put one needle into hold, knit across.
Hang some weights.
Can you see that this is the same
sequence that we started with?
We're creating a full pyramid.
There are 12 needles and hold on each side
of the work and we're just knitting in the
center.
Continue putting needles in hold on each
side until you've gotten all the way down
to only one needle in work.
Complete the pyramid by putting
needles back into work, one at a time.
Opposite the carriage needle into work,
knit across .Needle under work, knit
across needle.
Needle into work knit across.
Now this complete that
center full pyramid.
End
with the carriage and the
working yarn on the right.
We'll now put the 12 needles in the
left into middle position so they knit.
We'll pass the carriage
across to the left.
We're on the home stretch.
We're done with the center 24
needles and we'll put them in hold.
The right 12 needles
are also still in hold.
Now don't forget, the carriage remains
set to hold throughout this whole project.
Carriage is on the left.
Starting knitting a half pyramid
across the needles in work.
Opposite the carriage,
put a needle into hold.
Knit over and back.
Opposite the carriage,
put a needle into hold.
Over and back.
Repeat this until there's
one needle in work.
Then return the needles back one at a
time, just like before, needle in work
knit over, knit back, needle
in work knit over, knit back.
You're going to end with
the carriage on the left.
Put all the needles into middle position
or working position so that they all knit.
We're going to knit one row all across all
of the needles and we will have completed
one pattern repeat.
We'll complete this sequence for
the desired length of the scarf.
Section one has a full pyramid on the
left and a full pyramid on the right.
Section two has a half pyramid on the
left and right, and a full pyramid in the
center.
You see how they're
alternating for the pattern?
When your scarf is complete,
knit, a few rows bind off loosely.
And you're all done.
Thanks to the folks at Knit-1 for
sharing this fun, fun pattern.
It's great practice for short row
shaping, and I'm sure you'll get lots of
compliments on your scarf.
Happy knitting.